hey guys welcome back again to the
gamespot stage I'm still camera Manson
i'm still in my wonderful orange chair
but something new happened guys the
earth is doomed we have to leave Earth
and find a new home fortunately we have
just the man to tell us how to go about
doing this how to build a habitat in
space Charles I understand you're gonna
build us a habitat in space when the
earth goes to hell is that solute Lee
well an tastic more importantly you get
to build a habitat we go to say so yeah
I'll show you how trust me to do that
the whole earth is gonna trust you oh
god we're doing with a chair you're
sitting in seriously yeah okay this is
coming with me commander so your game is
cool habitat yes tell us about it what's
going on habitats a game about building
space stations out of space junk it's a
strategic space survival game wow ok out
of space junk so just like absolutely
butts we've left up in the atmosphere
from previous space launches or as
asteroids or part of it that's that's
only one part sure there's all that
stuff there's rockets and their
satellites but there's all kinds of
stuff that you wouldn't even imagine
there's mega yachts the Statue of
Liberty's head is up there the Eiffel
Tower because you said it yourself the
earth is doomed so what are we gonna do
we're gonna put booster rockets on
everything fly it up and lay it all up
there it's beautifully like futurama or
something that's amazing it does he does
sound like that it's the year eleven
thousand so you know you can say that is
absolutely so we can walk through the
game and and [ __ ] what's going on so
habitat as I said all about putting
together your own space station so it is
sea of space junk you can see it all
around you i mean we go right for the
Lady Liberty right I bet you can grab
that why she a cyborg why is there a red
donor like I said your 11,000 ecology
side wish I related by absolutely
absolutely now we start you out in this
in this version with a starter habitat
you can see it's kind of put together
with a little ramshackle stuff now it's
as easy as just grabbing anything you
want and saying you know I want the
shipping containers and I want that
thing and I want a particle Canada me
because who doesn't want one of those
right and you know you have your full
option you can turn stuff around set it
up any way you want to and your
engineers they're taking care of it for
you all at once check it out these guys
are working hard you've got a mini cam
up in the right-hand corner so you can
see what they see it's especially cool
when they go twisting and flying off
like
like crazy space space knots and then of
course as you grow you're going to need
to manage your oxygen food electricity
on board to keep your people alive so
what you do is you actually upgrade the
pieces that you've added so for this is
gas tank it can be an electric generator
an oxygen generator now you can't live
in it and you can't grow food in it so
you're going to need to figure out which
pieces you need to get bigger to grow
bigger and have more people on board now
eventually you're going to be so big
there's not going to be any resources
around you that's when you strap on the
rockets and you take your city for a
spin you actually fly using rocket
physics now you can see with only two
rockets on board I've kind of made like
a design error here clearly it's only
going to be able to oh it's only gonna
be learning you doing mr. well you know
survival this isn't easy because you
just killed mankind's last I like I like
to think of it as fast I'd like to think
of it as avoiding hitting the Statue of
Liberty's head thank you very much now
flying around is dangerous in space but
it's not the only issue you're not the
only habitat out there I mean there's
enemy habitats they're gonna be coming
to get your resources see why you want
that plasma cannon exactly nothing we're
gonna get a chance to use that out but
overhear you here's a great example of
what you can do you can build as many
habitats as you want some can be
strictly for offensive use this is my
favorite this is called the Ripper it's
just a big old grappling hook and two
big rockets so i just snagged that whole
enemy habitat now i'm gonna probably
fire and forget it's gonna fire both
those rockets we're gonna go straight
for we're going to grab that enemy
habitat yank him in half and smash them
to this guy's yacht there we go that was
a bit of a suicide mission though right
well you know was and oh this rocket is
not stopping either I think it's gonna
go it's gonna go right into the orbital
boundary it's gonna burn up in orbit so
obvious if you if you go too close to
you get sucked down in Sarah's
gravitation to and it doesn't matter
doesn't matter whether it's an engineer
your habitat the Eiffel Tower if it
falls in the atmosphere it burns up
that's game over for that piece of a4
piece of space junk so you're building
you're upgrading your flying you're
fighting the craziest creations that you
can make I mean that's what we're
encouraging and habitat okay so syllabi
making just like ridiculous bases and
then I'm trying to survive so what's
what's the difficulty like I mean
you know that look pretty you know they
keep will fully destroyed your your
beautiful thing and then you be all
about this massive guns exactly so it
yeah how difficult is it the the way
that the way to think about habitats
difficulty is we want you to build
something that you care about something
that will survive and as you see it's a
little tough to survive as you upgrade
you'll be able to buff up your habitat
so that you will be able to survive
you're gonna be dealing with threats
from the exterior like the bad guys and
the nano machines that are eating earth
coming up and trying to attack oh so
that's what happened Natalie that's
right Randall machine plague and they'll
come up and he'll try to attack you as
well and then the internal difficulties
are going to be the fact that your
citizens aren't very good at living in
space they're going to continuously set
fires they're going to press the airlock
eject button because they thought it was
the flush on the space toilet you're
going to have to deal with crises on
board your station the difficulty is
going to be that mix between the
external craziness and the internal kind
of almost like the the FTL kind of
what's going on inside your station in a
lot of ways the gate there's like two
games at once and you get to switch
between them as you upgrade build and go
out to try to survive is it quite
relaxed pressure or is that constant
like oh god I'm running out of oxygen oh
god I need to do this but now oh I've
been tough food like yeah I have much
this attention build the best the best
way to answer that is to tell you that
the community is going to help us decide
where the place is because habitat is
coming to steam early access in July
next month we're going to be out there
for people to play to give us feedback
to tell us hey I want junk that does
this or that or you know all these other
things and and without the without the
help of the community I mean a game like
this we we live or die by the community
that we have so we're going to we're
going to go full-on early access July
and we're going to find out answers to
those questions with your help fantastic
so is it like currently a single player
experience or could it be like online
multiplayer or what you were your
thoughts it is a single player
experience right now I will tell you
we've been at GDC at PAX East here at e3
the number one request is will you have
multiplayer and you know if your padded
abacoa PvP we're exploring all the
options
and not to sound like a broken record
but it's going to come down to the
community and thinking if we get the
love if they really want it and if we've
got what it's you know got what it takes
in that core community will drive for it
we're going to give you what you want
out of this game fantastic so M the
dangers that you are encountering as
you're trying to build your space
station yeah do you have to contend to
things like like radiation you know or
from you know Europe your people being
in space for too long and they're
growing both wasting and I mean how how
how much should be going into like the
kind of hardcore science students of it
I mean do you need to worry about little
bits of space debris coming through and
punching holes in your station or there
is a bit more relaxed and we've
encountered we've encountered some of
these questions already as we built it
one of the things we had to do in the
very beginning was we actually had to
nerf some of the damage because it would
create an unstoppable chain reaction
that's actually a real thing it's called
the Kessler syndrome and you can create
an unstable environment in space now
you're screwed you'll never be able to
fly in space again we actually had to
stop that from happening because it
wasn't any fun and so things like bone
wasting and radiation the answer is as
we explore it we say well what's going
to make this game more fun more creative
and add to that experience and if it is
fun and it is creative it's a candidate
for going in if we discover it's not fun
and the folks don't like it well it's a
game get it out of there well seeing as
I'm seeing is this all about you know
the reaction to community if you're
watching at home and you have any
questions for Christopher then you
should tweet at me right now at cam fraz
Rob I set at see a MFR a said our OB
it's like my name splitting the
treatment so anyway but tweet there and
then those questions I will throw a
Christopher because he obviously want
your feedback so you could right now you
could decide the direction of habitat
yeah whatever do whatever the pressure
is on standby I mean Wes something in
the game in the next tweet I can't
guarantee you'll go in the game all
right so let's do that he just he just
guaranteed it I just guaranteed it yeah
I'm gonna fly and I'm gonna fly my
little love let's just show a bit more
if the game playoff here absolutely well
right now I'm trying to get this thing
to not hit the nuclear missile and I
totally failed um but it's our nuclear
missiles but yeah well like I say you
know people are asking what statue
Liberty doing an orbit and I'm like well
why wouldn't it be there well we have
our first question sorry ready you ready
I am so steer Hopkins says could I
expand habitats outside our solar system
? how big is the universe how big is
your game player so it is current
version habitat is really focused on
Earth orbit and we have several
different orbits that we plan to work in
so one is just sort of a close in Earth
orbit and we're going to go all the way
out to what's called the graveyard orbit
where everything is sort of dead for us
that's almost like it's gonna be like an
alien graveyard experience you can find
very strange stuff out there now we
we're trying to keep earth sort of
central to the plot of the game and so
right now i can tell you it'll be an
experience that'll start from Earth and
go significantly out past into orbit
could we go to other planets well I
guess we'll have to find out but for now
we want to question part of that that
experience see the first question so
habitat was kick-starts he said right
that's right yeah but not process I was
I was that for you guys it was it was
incredible um Kickstarter we did a
30-day Kickstarter starting in April
second we felt it would be a pretty bad
idea to start a Kickstarter in April
Fool's Day yeah probably not a good idea
so we waited one day and then we fired
it off now we went for 30 days we we set
a target $50,000 we got such a great
response from the community we raised
sixty four thousand dollars we we were
so grateful and continue to be grateful
that we have the money to survive and
build this game and get to early access
one of the things that my my mentors
told me as we got the Kickstarter
process started his stop development on
your game seriously it is a full-time
job to run a Kickstarter and they were
dead right they are so right because
every day was twitch streaming and
talking to the press and sharing the
love and the excitement I I was I was
just so excited to wake up every day and
see and talk with people it was huge I'm
but i will say kind of like a conference
when you get when you get done all you
want to do is go back and keep working
on your game and so is it was really
exciting so which which that kind of
group of game players you think you're
you're peeling see like wish fans of
like well you mean like strategy games
like civilizations you think or are like
which audience you think you're kind of
you're getting people from but this year
because it's a new game is yes
quite a quite unique concept really I
feel like it scratches a lot of
different itches her for gamers and
that's kind of and that's kind of how
what I am I i I'd abble in all kinds of
games i'm a huge fan of the sim games
i'm a huge kerbal space program nut FTL
I've got it on every single system
including ipad and of course you know
civilization is huge Sid Meier is an
icon of mine and the new the reboot of
XCOM was basically like my game of the
year for like oh yeah I know it was huge
so as a fresh I feel like the the
players that play these games are living
in those worlds they're they're looking
for a new experience to build space
they're looking for a new experience to
create things and they're ready to get a
little silly there they're ready to geek
out and have some fun let's have a look
at a little bit more gameplay before you
got some more nude amateur absolutely
absolutely let me just let me just uh
let me just run run it real quick here
and we'll pop in we'll try a few other
things that I like to do let me drop a
few of these shipping containers we
talked about that particle cannon we
didn't get to use it I want to use all
right get this thing on board so I'm
gonna put the particle cannon right here
next to the gas tank because that's a
brilliant and hoping to go ahead and
select this guy right here I'm going to
upgrade it so we have enough electricity
to fire this bad boy and while I'm
waiting for these guys to bring their
stuff in say hi to the space dog space
dog hey little guy of course I see you
boo-boo I guess he's a robot dog right
well no he's a real dog he's just going
out for a walk right now oh he's in a
space suit I wish you the ocean dog in a
space suit yeah of course where we go
and i'll put a booster rocket right on
the particle cannon and we're gonna get
this thing going now check this out the
particle cannon that we have right here
we're going to fire this baby and it's
actually a push beam if I turn this
thing on and leave it on I'm gonna go
ahead and fire the Rockets we're gonna
go ahead and drag it over here we're
gonna start pushing this stuff all over
the place we're gonna get crazy oh man
it's gonna be it's gonna be a little
nuts and that's the only gonna end in
tears exactly okay now want to turn all
the Rockets on let's do this thing I
think you just play this game because
you just like to build them to destroy
your creation Charles so will you seem
to be doing good luck surviving at all
you know if this scenario ever happens
in real life I am NOT putting you in
charge I'm not I'm not an evil man
and I'm giving and I'm giving everybody
else command I think I think it's I
think there's going to be people out
there ninety-nine percent of the gaming
community will be way better commanders
than i can ever best will chose it be an
absolute pleasure having you on stage
and showing up habitat so thank you very
much for doing that enjoy their what's
left to be 30